David, which of these topics do you
think are applied to using a script?
>> So I chose four of the seven
as applied to using a script.
So for problem reduction, we saw earlier
that the script breaks down the overall
scene into smaller scenes, and
even further into smaller actions.
What that means is that when
we're executing the script,
and it kind of gets caught
somewhere we can break it down and
see exactly where the script got caught.
So we can see exactly where
an expectation was violated.
Classification we actually already
discussed because classification
can help us identify which script to
execute in a given situation based on
what we see.
So if we walk into a restaurant and
see a hostess for
example we can classify that as
a specific kind of restaurant and
launch the script that
goes along with it.
Although it would take a bigger jump,
I can also imagine putting
a script in terms of formal logic.
Especially because we discussed before,
that a script can be considered a plan
that has already been executed once, and
can be transferred to new situations.
So if we're discussing plans
in the form of formal logic,
we may also be able to put scripts
in those same kind of terms.
In terms of what they're asserting is
true for a given state of the script.
So if we could put plans in
the form of formal logic,
we can also imagine rewriting our
script in the form of formal logic.
That would give us a script in
terms of what different elements
of the script assert about the state
of the world at different points of
the script's execution.
Finally, we can also see understanding
applying pretty directly to scripts
because it helps us disambiguate
similar events in different situations.
So to go with Ashok's example about
receiving the bill right when you sit
down at the table, understanding talks
about how we can disambiguate that event
based on what else has
happened before and after.
I didn't see the other three as
being as applicable to scripts for
a couple different reasons.
For Generate & Test and
Means-Ends Analysis,
these are problem solving methods.
And as we talked about with planning in
the previous exercise, scripts are often
used when we already have a solution and
we simply need to execute it.
Case-Based Reasoning keeps things at the
level of individual cases that can be
adapted to our current problem.
Where as scripts serve as
an abstraction over a number of cases.
So I don't really see case-based
reasoning applying as much here either.
>> This is good, David.
Thank you for sharing this.
Note that Generate and & Test, and
Case-Based Reasoning might be able to
have the ability to
use scripts after all.
So one can imagine a situation where
there are a large number of scripts
available and the robot has to decide
which of the scripts should I use for
a particular situation.
And may not be able to classify
the situation dashed into scripts and
with that case the robot will pick
a script, generate it, try it out,
see if it works,
if it does not pick another one.
Also Case-Based Reasoning is currently
the application of scripts in the sense
that both Case-Based Reasoning and
script-based reasoning
are extremely memory intensive.
What both of them are saying is
that memory often supplies most of
the answer.
Like we said earlier when we were
discussing Case-Based Reasoning,
we don't think as much
as we think we do.
Most of the time memory
gives us the answer.
The difference, of course, like David
pointed out is, that cases defer to
instances whereas scripts
are abstractions of the instances.